new questions about ties between a
member of president Trump's inner circle
and Russian officials The Washington
Post reports that the president's
son-in-law and senior adviser Jared
Kushner discussed setting up a secret
communications channel between the Trump
transition team and Russia according to
the paper intercepts of Russian
communications reveal Russian ambassador
Sergei kis lyac told his superiors in
Moscow that Kushner made the proposal
during a December meeting at Trump Tower
here in New York a meeting that was also
attended by Michael Flynn the now ousted
national security adviser the report
also says Kushner suggested using
Russian diplomatic facilities in the
United States for those communications
Errol Barnett is in our Washington
bureau with the latest
Erol good morning good morning the
report comes as the FBI is scrutinizing
Krishna's contacts with Russian
officials last year in addition to his
December meeting with Ambassador kis
lyac the bureau is also looking at
Krishna's interactions with a Moscow
banker tied to Russian security services
he is so great if you can't produce
peace in the Middle East
nobody can speaking on the eve of his
inauguration president-elect Donald
Trump praised his 36 year old son-in-law
and advisor Jared Kushner I have a
feeling that Jared is going to do a
great job Kushner a core pillar of
Trump's in a circle had been operating
as the chief conduit between Donald
Trump and foreign officials during the
campaign Kushner is not accused of any
wrongdoing but the FBI is now
scrutinizing his contact with Russian
officials as part of its ongoing
investigation into Russian interference
they are specifically looking at a
December meeting with Russian ambassador
Sergey kiss lyac at Trump Tower and a
follow-up meeting suggested by the
Ambassador with Sergey Gourcuff the
chairman of Russian state-owned Bank VEB
his bank is currently sanctioned by the
United States and Krishna did not
initially disclose those private
meetings Democrats like California's ted
Lieu now want the president's trusted
adviser punished he is now in a
compromising position he needs to have
his security clearance suspended in a
statement Kushner's attorney said
mr. Kushner previously volunteered to
share with Congress what he knows about
these meetings he will do the same if
he's contacted in connection with any
other inquiry Trump associates already
facing FBI scrutiny include former
campaign chairman Paul Manafort former
national security adviser Michael Flynn
former foreign policy adviser caught a
page and longtime trump associate
Rajasthan now former FBI director James
Comey who has agreed to testify in front
of the Senate Intelligence Committee is
still coordinating exactly when to do so
he's working with newly appointed
special prosecutor Robert Muller to
determine what he can and cannot say
publicly Alex Errol Barnett with the
latest in our Washington bureau thanks
Errol